Alex Barrera he's got a head like like  you know those Easter Island statues so  I'm happy to yeah expose him when it's  time and I already said I'm going to  make this a horror movie but hey man  sometimes people sleep through horror  movies so  when it's time to work I know what I do  when I get busy I get busy but right now  I'm like he's got bragging rights he can  talk all the [ __ ] he wants I don't even  have to try and intimidate him he's not  very I don't it doesn't work on him so  same with me I don't know if he's going  to try and intimidate me good luck this  doesn't work on me but um I hope  he thinks he's going to walk in there  and walk through me I hope he thinks  that because he's going to be in for a  rude awakening but again maybe not maybe  I might just [ __ ] I don't know run  around and and then try and Escape him  and maybe jump out the cage who knows  but hey stay tuned that's why you got to  watch the fight you'll see